der bundesminister für gesundheit herr
professor doktor karl lauterbach und sie
stellen uns bekanntlich das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz vor besser laufe
das beginnt der minister bitte vielen
dank ich möchte mich zunächst einmal
ganz herzlich bedanken dass wir hier in
ihrem ordnung tagen dürfen bedanke mich
auch bei justizminister marco buschmann
für die gute zusammenarbeit in der
vorbereitung dieses gesetzes was dort im
kabinett beschlossen haben das gesetzt
hat eigentlich eine ganz simple aufgabe
wir wollen im jetzt kommenden herbst
dort nicht besser für die pandemie
gerüstet sein dass das in der
vergangenheit der fall gewesen ist und
ich rechne mit einer deutlichen kroner
welle im herbst aber dass es hier nicht
maßgeblich sondern maßgeblich ist sollte
eine solche welle kommen müssen wir gut
vorbereitet sein dazu bieten wir vor
beratungen durch den bund an und wir
ermächtigen die länder möglich mit
möglichkeiten auf die pandemie zu
reagieren
das von uns bereits erwähnte
sieben-punkte-programm muss ich ihn
nicht einmal vorstellen aber der siebte
punkt ist eben das
infektionsschutzgesetz und da
ermöglichen wir es den ländern mit einer
masken pflicht mit impfungen mit
obergrenzen im autoinnenraum in einem
stufenplan vorzugehen das ziel dieser
maßnahmen ist dass wir todesfälle
schwere longo wie verläuft schwere
verläufe aber auch die überlastung der
infrastruktur und die belastungen der
kliniken vermeiden das sind die ziele
der maßnahmen die wir heute beschlossen
haben und bundesrat soll daher ab dem
ersten
zehnten gelten dass also in den fern und
im flugverkehr zwei masken getragen
werden müssen das also in krankenhäusern
und pflegeeinrichtungen
die schutzniveaus erhöht werden das
dauert die ffb zwei masken sich geht und
darüber hinaus getestet wird also im
vergleich zum letzten jahr erhöhen wir
dort die aus den schutzmaßnahmen noch
einmal war die also derzeit also
kursierende omikron der a5 variante
ansteckender ist als varianten die wir
im letzten jahr gehabt haben darüber
hinaus also ermöglichen wir es den
ländern in zwei stufen auf die pandemie
entwicklung zu reagieren
zunächst einmal also in der stufe 1 auf
den ersten zehn ist es den ländern dann
also in abhängigkeit von der entwicklung
der fallzahlen und der gesamtschau der
pandemie möglich eine masken pflicht für
die innenräume
also zuvor zu sehen wenn man dass solche
masken pflicht vorgesehen ist dann
müssen die länder auch die ausnahme
einer testung ermöglichen das heißt
derjenige der dann getestet ist erster
masken pflicht befreit aber die masken
sicht kann eingeführt werden wird sie
eingeführt dann ist diese ermöglichung
einer also testen dort wo das möglich
ist vorzusehen durch die länder darüber
hinaus haben wir andere regelung
verändert im vergleich zu den ihnen
vorliegenden entwurf von vor wenigen
wochen und zwar haben wir die
möglichkeit das also in den innenräumen
von der test von der testung also
abstand genommen wird und die masken
pflicht also abgegolten wird durch eine
frische impfung oder durch eine frische
genesung diese regelung halten wir
weiterhin für sinnvoll die machen wir
aber jetzt als kann regelung für die
länder das heißt die länder können die
masken sicht in den innenräumen vorsehen
und können dann also im rahmen dieser
massen pflicht diejenigen die frisch
geimpft sind oder fisch genesen sind und
das sind jeweils also diejenigen die vor
drei monaten spätestens geimpft worden
sind oder genießen sind von der masken
pflicht befreien somit muss einfach zu
machen wenn die masken pflicht kommt
weil das paar nie geschehen ist also
notwendig macht von den ländern
beschlossen dann kann der test als eine
alternative zur maske gesehen werden die
länder können es aber ermöglichen dass
stattdessen eine frische impfung oder
eine fläche genesung wird wir wollen das
vereinfacht indem wir die korona waren
er grün kennzeichnen ich werde meine
krone waren heute nicht noch einmal hoch
halten weil sie nie erfahren sie alles
schon gesehen und
somit also ist diese regelung also
fortgesetzt worden sie sah es als eine
kann regelung der länder also vorgesehen
worden darüber hinaus haben natürlich
also die veranstalter wie auch die also
gastronomie wie auch also die bars cafés
und restaurants die haben die
möglichkeit also mit vom hausrecht
gebrauch zu machen die können dann zum
beispiel ihre einrichtungen also so
führen dass man entweder nur mit einer
maske zutritt hat und dann nur mit einem
test oder beispielsweise mit einem test
oder einer frischen impfung oder einer
flächen genesung das sind die regeln die
ab dem 1 durch die regierungen der
länder ermöglicht werden können wenn die
pandemie das notwendig macht die fahrt
zahlen steigern die kritische
infrastruktur ist bedroht der pandemie
radar zeigt also also ein dynamisches
infektionsgeschehen wir haben viele tote
oder wir haben viele schwere verläufe
dann können die länder in der
gesamtschau dieser kriterien eine zweite
stufe hier finden und diese zweite stufe
würde vorsehen dass die masken pflicht
im innenraum grundsätzlich gilt dass es
dann keine ausnahmen mehr gipfel
getestete durch genießen oder sich
geimpfte es kann dann auch vorgesehen
werden dass in den innenräumen wie auch
draußen abstands gebote gelten und es
kann dann auch vorgesehen seien das also
obergrenzen für die innenräume gelten
sodass also zum beispiel in den
restaurants oder in den cafés oder aber
in den auch bei den veranstaltung nur
eine bestimmte zahl von personen zutritt
hat so dass wir dann quasi noch einmal
nachlegen können die durch die also
regeln die über schlossen habe insgesamt
glaube ich dass ein gutes
instrumentarium
also masken pflicht wir haben impfungen
platz wir haben zwischen der genesenen
ausweise wir haben testungen am platz
wir haben sogar die möglichkeit also die
masken pflicht in den außen rahmen
vorzugeben wenn also in dieser zweiten
stufe das notwendig ist wir haben die
möglichkeit dass also die ausnahmen für
die innenraum masken pflicht aufgehoben
wird und wir können den obergrenzen
einführen also ein breites
instrumentarium
ich hoffe nicht dass es in der gänze
eingesetzt werden muss aber es muss
eingesetzt werden können und darauf
haben wir uns verständigt schließlich
wir haben uns auch darauf verständigt
dass es einen weiteren lockdown oder
schulschließungen nicht geben wird in
den schulen ist vorgesehen dass masken
vorgegeben werden können ab der fünften
klasse in den kitas und in den aus
grundschulen können auch festungen
vorgegeben werden aber von
schulschließungen oder schließung und
andere art und lockt an regelungen haben
wir abstand genommen vielen dank und
herr minister dr was machst du denn da
ganz herzlichen dank auch ich bedanke
mich für die gastfreundschaft und dass
wir hier ein gutes moderates und
maßvolles konzept vorgelegt haben in der
rollenverteilung ist es natürlich so der
gesundheitsminister kümmert sich um die
gesundheit und der justizminister
kümmert sich um die frage ob die
verfahren die verhältnismäßigkeit und
auch den grundrechtsschutz ausreichend
ausreichend gewährleistet ist ich will
einmal was zum verfahren sagen ich
glaube dass wir ein hohes maß an
transparenz in diesem verfahren und auch
an qualitätssicherung gewährleistet
haben wie vielleicht noch nie in der
pandemie denn wir haben uns ja exakt an
den fahrplan gehalten den wir auch schon
im frühjahr angekündigt haben da gab es
ja die sunset klausel für die maßnahmen
wir hatten im gesetz den termin zu dem
der evaluierungsbericht uns vorliegt und
diese termine waren auch so angeordnet
dass dazwischen beratungen in der
regierung stattfinden konnten beratung
mit den ländern stattfinden konnten und
jetzt auch ein reguläres
gesetzgebungsverfahren
beim bundestag stattfinden kann ich
glaube das ist erstmal ein gewinn weil
dadurch
gewährleistet war dass diese ideen und
vorschläge natürlich ganz anders
rückgekoppelt werden können auch wir
haben ja unseren ersten vorschlag vor
drei wochen schon der öffentlichkeit
präsentiert und auch in diesem
zusammenhang gab es ja rückmeldung
kommentierung auch aus den ländern aus
der wissenschaft auf die man eingehen
konnte also ich glaube ein so hohes maß
an transparenz an planbarkeit auch an
konsultationsprozesses hat es noch nicht
gegeben und das ist ein stück verfahrens
klugheit ist meine erste bemerken die
zweite bemerkung ist natürlich die wenn
es um die frage geht maßnahmen brauchen
wir das überhaupt und ich weiß es gibt
gerade in der jetzigen stimmung wo wir
eine sehr stabile lage haben im moment
so das gefühl kann dieser ganze mist
nicht einfach vorbei sein und offen
geständig führt man das auch am liebsten
wünschen aber das virus ist eben nicht
weg und wir bereiten uns ja nicht auf
eine lage vor für den fall dass alles so
bleibt wie es jetzt ist sondern wir
müssen uns vorbereiten auf eine lage wie
sie mutmaßlich sagen mal im herbst
winter eintreten kann und zwar nach
annahme auch kritischer
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
und die sagen uns dass eine lage
eintreten kann dass wir eben noch mal in
eine schwierige situation geraten auf
die muss man sich vor moral warum ist
dieses paket maß voll das einzige was
wir für den herbst winter über das
hinaus was bekannt ist qualitativ
wirklich als bundesgesetzgeber
einheitlich anordnen sind ja die höheren
sicherheitsstandards in den
krankenhäuser und ein altenpflegeheim
und das halte ich auch für absolut
richtig und geboten denn dort haben wir
sehr viele menschen die wohl ne rabl
sind für die also auch eine relevantes
sterblichkeitsrisiko besteht und diese
maßnahme gibt es auch in anderen
europäischen ländern teilweise wurden
sie dort sogar im sommer durchgehalten
und deshalb ist das eine vernünftige und
auch angemessene maßnahme um hier
besonders schutzwürdigen gruppen einen
angemessenen schutz zu bieten wir haben
leider die erfahrung
in den anderen corona wellen machen
müssen insbesondere im herbst und winter
dass wir eben dort besonders viele opfer
zu beklagen haben deshalb muss man etwas
tun alles andere was wir vor sehen sind
ja eine rechtsgrundlage also optionen
die die länder ziehen können aber nicht
müssen
und ich will auch noch mal was dazu
sagen weil ja solche gesetzestexte
manchmal auch sehr
munter und kreativ interpretiert werden
was da geschrieben es ist der maximale
rahmen bis zu dem man gehen kann die
länder können aber immer auch wenig
weniger machen also sie müssen davon
nicht gebrauch machen sie können bei
masken innenraum beispielsweise von
können sie gebrauch machen können das
aber auch ab schattiert tun also sie
können bestimmte branchen aus nehmen sie
können bestimmte institutionen aus
nehmen das haben wir in der begründung
auch noch mal klargestellt körper einer
dienstleistung aber ein bundesland
könnte auch sagen ich mache masken
pflicht zb bei behörden weil da alle
menschen hingehen müssen ja weil da auch
honorable hingehen müssen ich nehme aber
die gastronomie oder die hochschulen
oder so aus dass geht also als ein hoch
flexibles instrument mit dem man der
lage vor ort gerecht wird wir haben
besonders lange gerungen das ist auch
kein geheimnis aber sind da glaube ich
zu einem sehr ordentlichen guten
kompromiss gekommen bei den schulen denn
das will ich hier sagen die schülerinnen
und schüler waren sicherlich die gruppe
die am meisten in der pandemie gelitten
haben und
ich will jetzt gar nicht so sehr
zurückblicken aber dieser gruppe haben
wir wirklich am meisten zugemutet
insbesondere was die ausübung ihres
rechts auf bildung angeht insbesondere
was die schulschließung angeht und
deshalb bin ich auch froh dass wir uns
zügig darauf einigen konnten dass die
das instrument der schulschließung also
völlig unverhältnismäßig ist und dass
wir auch beim instrument der maske eben
hier die jungen schülerinnen und schüler
die kinder raus nehmen bis zur klasse 4
und ansonsten folgende regel gilt ab
klasse 5 können die bundesländer ja auch
nicht einfach sagen zur allgemeinen
pandemie abwehr mache ich jetzt maske an
den schulen sondern dort ist ja der
gedanke der im gesetz steht wenn die
alternative wäre dass ansonsten
beispielsweise durch hohe zahl von
krankheitsfällen in den lehrerkollegien
kein präsenzunterricht mehr aufrecht
erhalten kann und wir ansonsten die
ganze klassen und jahrgänge nach hause
schicken müssen dann ist es doch besser
mit medizinischer maske
präsenzunterricht anbieten zu können als
keinen präsenzunterricht anbieten zu
können und ich glaube das ist eine
vernünftige regelung und dann war
zwischenzeitlich in der diskussion mit
den ländern noch mal unklar ist das
wirklich eine harte rechtliche
voraussetzungen es in der begründung
noch mal klar gestellt also dieser
gedanke gilt
ansonsten bin ich auch noch mal was zu
der zweiten stufe sagen die kollege
lauterbach erwähnt hat auch hier ging es
natürlich darum einen rechtsstaatlichen
standard zu wahren und dieses zweite
fach des werkzeugkastens ist ja durch
zwei vorhängeschlössern gesichert dass
eine vorhängeschloss ist natürlich die
demokratische legitimation durch einen
landtagsbeschluss
und das zweite vorhängeschloss ist
natürlich etwas was sie schon kennen aus
der jetzigen rechtslage dass die
bundesländer eine konkrete gefahr für
die kritische infrastruktur dann dort
auch feststellen müssen dass ist ein
gefahrenabwehr rechtlich bekannter
begriff damit wissen juristen auch was
anzufangen und der ist auch gerichtlich
überprüfbar und selbst wenn das der fall
ist haben wir oft der rechtsfolgen seite
sehr maßvolle maßnahmen wir haben auch
einige instrumente gegenüber der
jetzigen rechtslage sogar aus dem
werkzeugkasten rausgenommen sie alle
kennen die 2g 3g
zugangsbeschränkungen die die alte
hotspot regelung vorsieht die haben wir
rausgenommen weil die auch wirklich sehr
umstritten war und vom evaluierungs
gremium auch als nicht sehr zweckmäßig
empfunden wurde also auch dort haben wir
maßvolle regeln und
insbesondere das thema masken im
außenbereich das ist ja viel diskutiert
worden es ist ja nicht masken
außenbereich sondern ist maske bei
veranstaltungen also wir reden nicht
über die einkaufsstraße
sondern es ist maske bei veranstaltungen
die draußen stattfinden die anderthalb
metern nicht eingehalten werden können
also auch da haben wir den
anwendungsbereich auf die wirklich
relevanten fälle so begrenzt so dass
sich insgesamt sagen möchte in
anbetracht der tatsache dass wir uns
vorbereiten müssen haben wir hier den
bundesländern ein paket an die hand
gegeben sehr maßvoller regelung die auch
wenn wir uns in europa umschauen sich
maßvoll verhalten also die immer wieder
gehörte behauptung deutschland sei hier
also als geisterfahrer unterwegs oder
niemand würde das tun das entspricht
nicht der tatsache viele länder haben
entweder noch permanente regelungen die
teilweise sehr viel schärfere
grundrechtseingriffe ermöglichen und
viele europäische länder bereiten jetzt
auch gesetzliche grundlagen für den
herbst winter vor niederlande frankreich
finnland viele länder sind genau in der
debatte in dem wir uns jetzt befinden
und wir haben im vergleich zu diesen
entwürfen hier ein sehr moderates
grundrechtsschutzes konzept vorgelegt
und damit möchte ich meine ausführungen
dank herr minister so wir haben eine
knappe halbe eine gute halbe stunde noch
zeit für ihre fragen weil danach
bekanntlich die
regierungspressekonferenz ist viele
fragen habe ich schon notiert ich weiß
nicht ob alle dran kommen aber wir als
linke beginnt dann die kollegen dort
ja danke schön eine frage die sich
eigentlich an beide minister richtet es
hat ja aus den ländern den vorwurf
gegeben und auch in der öffentlichen
debatte dass sein neuer flickenteppich
entsteht jetzt haben wir eben ganz oft
das wort oder gehört oder oder also
können sie nochmal bitte erklären warum
sie keine sorge haben offensichtlich
dass es in deutschland einen neuen
provider flickenteppich besteht wo sich
jeder wenn er eine andere stadt geht
oder bundesland wechselt neuen von mir
muss welche regeln eigentlich wo gilt
ja vielleicht fange ich an ich glaube
das wird sehr simpel sich also
darstellen ich persönlich gehe davon aus
dass also wir im oktober dass ich
schwierigkeiten
bekommen werden und das dann also viele
länder sich also überlegen werden
anzuwenden das heißt ich gehe nicht
davon aus so das ist ein gesetz das nur
zum schluss also auf dem papier stand
sondern ich gehe davon aus dass wir
leider muss ich sagen ich ihr gern aber
ich gehe davon aus dass wir tatsächlich
in die situation kommen werden das
gesetz anwenden zu müssen wir haben
jetzt schon also in vielen kliniken eine
so starke belastung in den abteilungen
die notfallversorgung darstellen und
auch die noten versorgten patienten dann
auf die normalen station übernehmen das
ist eine ungewöhnliche situation im
sommer das lässt erwarten dass wir also
im herbst also hiermit über forderungen
rechnen müssen dann kommen also diese
gesetze zum tragen was wird dann
passieren dann wird im innenraum die
masken pflicht gelten das wird also dann
also mit ausnahmen natürlich für
diejenigen die pflicht getestet sind aus
sondern wird werden wir jetzt zurück
sein weil der masken pflegt und es wird
dann auch sehr simpel das kann sich dann
maßen bürger auch sehr simpel merken das
wird dann so sein also dass die masken
pflicht gilt und dass sie also nicht
gilt wenn man frisch getestet ist das
wird ungefähr das wird dann werden das
so kommt wie ich das also vorher sehe
dass wir schwierigkeiten bekommen über
den op en v oder auch also in den
innenräumen in geschäften in den bars
restaurants und so weiter wird die
masken pflichten und mit der mit
einfachen test kann man sich dann also
wenn das müssen die länder anbieten kann
man sich dann von dermaßen pflicht
befreien wo das möglich ist wie es also
bei der zweiten stufe aussieht das ist
eine andere sache und was auch unklar
ist also wie weit die länder von dieser
regelung gebrauch machen dass auch
diejenigen die frisch geimpft wurde
frisch genesen sind also macht von der
aso masken pflicht ausgenommen sind ich
glaube dass die länder aber dass nur
eine kann regelung ist das nutzen werden
und zwar deshalb war der bürger der
jetzt frisch geimpft wurde mit dem
impfstoff sehr gut vor der
infektionsschutz wir müssen davon
ausgehen
wir können davon ausgehen dass die neue
neben stoffe erstmalig wieder auch gut
vor der infektion schützen also nicht
nur von schwerem verlauf dann werden die
bürger die jetzt aus um beispielsweise
in ein restaurant und die maske tragen
sollen oder fähig getestet sind werden
dann darauf hin aber wir sind doch nicht
hilft und dass man dann ausland hin
steht und sagt na ja sie sind zwar
frisch geimpft aber sie müssen trotzdem
sich testen lassen oder sie müssen die
maske tragen das glaube ich würde man
nicht lange es werden sich die länder
gut überlegen muss man so auszudrücken
von daher könnte ich mir vorstellen dass
es zu einheitlichen regelungen kommt wir
werden natürlich auch im vorfeld also
wenn der herbst kommt mit den ländern
darüber reden und versuchen mit den
ländern etwas hinzubekommen dass es
möglichst viel einheitlichkeit gibt also
das was wir jetzt hier verabredet haben
das sind ja wie minister buschmann also
beschrieben hat das sind ja also
regelungen die gemacht werden können wie
die länder die regeln dann anwenden ist
aus dem gesetz nicht vorgesehen aber es
kann natürlich sein dass wir uns dann
mit den ländern gemeinsam darauf einigen
das könnte eine gute umsetzung seien
somit ich rechne nicht mit einem
flickenteppich zum flicken täglich nur
zwei kurze anmerkungen einmal ist es ja
so er im vorfeld unserer beratung kamen
aus den ländern der wunsch nach einem
viel breiteren instrumentenkasten also
noch im juni hab ich ja sind ja papiere
veröffentlicht worden beispielsweise von
bayern hessen nordrhein-westfalen
baden-württemberg die viel schärfere
massnahmen verlangt haben kontakt
beschränkungen sie alle erinnern sich
das ist die grundlage dafür dass wir
demnächst zählen wie viel besuch bei der
oma zu weihnachten kommen kann also mit
diesen dingen beschäftigen uns nicht der
gesamte private bereich ist in die
eigenverantwortung der bürger gestellt
und allein schon dadurch dass das
instrumentarium schmalbandige geworden
ist ist ja schon mal eine größe ein
größerer einheitlichkeit sichergestellt
also die
möglichkeit zu variieren ist ja von
vornherein kleiner und zweitens muss ich
wirklich einen sagen mich hat dieses
pauschale schlagwort des flickenteppichs
noch nie überzeugt weil es ein prinzip
in unserem föderalen staat ist es die
gefahrenabwehr von den ländern vor ort
geregelt und besorgt wird also jedes
land hat sein eigenes polizeirechts ein
eigenes gefahrenabwehr recht und hier
haben wir die situation dass für den
infektionsschutz der bund zwar
gesetzgebung zuständig ist aber
natürlich die länder das machen je nach
lage vor ort und im gefahrenabwehr recht
gilt eben wenn ich eine schwierige
gefahren da habe dann kann ja auch mehr
maßnahmen machen und wir haben oft genug
in der pandemie gesehen dass die
situation in den bundesländern
unterschiedlich ist teilweise in den
großen flächenländern sogar sehr
unterschiedlich ist und weil unser credo
ist gefahren adäquates handeln zu
ermöglichen ist es also absolut sinnvoll
den bundesländern vor ort die
möglichkeit auf die lage vor ort zu
reagieren zu geben und nicht das ganze
land über einen kamm zu scheren so mit
der bitte sich auf möglichst eine
portierte frage zu konzentrieren damit
viele kolleginnen kollegen dran kommen
die kolleginnen dort in der mitte und
danach dann fiel um
guten tag rebecca soligie vom
nachrichtenportal watson herr buschmann
und härter was die beide haben gerade
den schulschließungen eine absage
erteilt wenn das als versprechen
gewertet werden kann wie genau soll das
tatsächlich ablaufen wenn die zahlen
aufgrund einer schlimmeren variante
beispielsweise im herbst durch die decke
schlagen würden ja also wir müssen da
gar nichts versprechen sondern unserer
panini konzept ist ja gesetzgeberisch im
künftigen paragraf 28 des
infektionsschutzgesetzes beschrieben
immer vorausgesetzt der gesetzgeber
beschließt das so wir machen ja nur
einen vorschlag das parlament wählt das
letzte wort und dort ist diese maßnahme
der pauschalen schulschließung also dass
eine landesregierung sagt ich mache die
schulen eben einfach zu zur
pandemievorsorge schlichtweg nicht
vorgesehen das heißt wenn ein land das
tun wollte fehlt ihm die rechtsgrundlage
davon nur damit ich die rechtsauskunft
auch vollständig gebe davon nicht
erfasst ist das was sowieso auch schon
volker immer möglich war wenn man an
einer einzelnen schule natürlich ein
ganz wildes pandemie geschehen hat das
gilt aber auch für einzelne betriebe
dann kann man mal auch eine einzelne
schule schließen das ging aber auch ohne
die korona sonderregelung weil das ja
wenn sie so wollen eine banalität
desinfektions rechts an sich ist aber
die maßnahme dass sich die kategorie
schule pauschal schließe die sieht das
gesetz nicht vor und offen gestanden das
ist auch richtig und wichtig so ich
erinnere da dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht ja ein
spezielles grundrecht der schülerinnen
und schüler auf schulische bildung noch
einmal unterstrichen hat und dem müssen
wir gerecht werden weil diese gruppe ich
wiederhole noch mal wirklich bislang
auch am meisten in der pandemie gelitten
hat nur ein satz dazu also ich glaube
ich weiß was die kollegin meint und das
steht auch nicht im widerspruch zu dem
was
sitz minister buschmann gerade so
eloquent vorgetragen hat aber es sind
natürlich denkbar dass es eine variante
gebe die also zum beispiel ganz
besonders kinder befällt besonders
schwere schwer verlaufen verwandt dass
es denkbar das glauben wir nicht dass
das so ist aber wenn dem so wäre dann
kämen natürlich der § 28a zum tagen und
dann kehren wir in eine ganz andere
pandemische lage davon ist aber jetzt in
keiner weise auszugehen ich möchte aber
der vollständigkeit halber darauf
hinweisen dass wir auch für solche also
nicht zu erwartenden veränderungen
vorbereitet werden erst setzte
allerdings einem beschluss des deutschen
bundestages forscher so ganz einfach
geht das nicht nur weil wir über die
frage der erwartungs sicherheit sprechen
28a ist sie erinnern sich die
epidemische lage nationaler tragweite
das ist ja ein instrument das wir still
gelegt haben und dass man nur
reaktivieren könnte wenn der bundestag
mit mehrheit das beschließen wird herr
jung dann ist entweder die leute hier
eine frage zu dem testzentren
haben sie eine plausibilitätsprüfung dem
bka
verordnet mich würde mal interessieren
seit wann hat denn das lkw kompetenzen
für kriminalitätsbekämpfung seit wann
weiß das lka wie man abrechnungsbetrug
erfasst bekommt das lka von ihm kein
extrageld kein extra personal
die cah frauen die das sonst hätten
machen müssen bekommen trotzdem
weiterhin geld obwohl diese selbst nie
machen wollen und immer selbst spricht
man von einer unverschämtheit ihrerseits
das ist ein großer witz sein darum würde
mich mal interessieren wie sie auf
dieses zitat schnaps idee gekommen sind
zunächst haben also die leitungsebene sr
k s mit einem stetigen austausch bin hat
sich bei mir was diese also aufgabe
angeht
im verständnisvoll gezeigt und ich habe
daher also bisher keine
beschwerden dieser art auf dieser ebene
gehört wenn man arbeitet also an der
umsetzung und zum zweiten es handelt
sich um eine statistische prüfung also
die also eigentliche abrechnung erfolgt
durch die kassenärztlichen vereinigung
oder weiter vermietet und danach erfolge
statistische prüfung auf deren grundlage
dann beispielsweise die
ermittlungsbehörden aber auch die
kommunen entsprechende also in schritte
einleiten können ich bin ein beispiel
wenn jetzt beispielsweise also in einer
situation
wo also hier
also ein relativ also unverändert das
pandemische geschehen beobachten dass
ich eine massive zunahme von tests in
einer bestimmten testeinrichtung also
sehen und dann das auch noch auffällig
ist dahingehend dass es fast nur test
sind die kostenlos erfolgt sind dann
muss man darüber nachdenken wie es denn
das möglich also was für gründe gibt es
denn dafür und das kann dann geprüft
werden das kann dann zum beispiel also
ganz natürliche konsequenz haben dass
das ein testzentrum ist was ich verlegt
hat und beispielsweise vor einer klinik
liegt so dass dort diejenigen getestet
werden die also in die klinik worden und
daher dass mich bezahlt werden muss es
ganz andere gründe haben aber durch
diese statistische auffälligkeit prüfung
die im vorfeld der eigentlichen
überprüfung der test sein geschieht
kommen wir ein ganzes stück weiter
sie hätten das also immer noch für
sinnvoll weil sie gerade die gespräche
mit der leitungsebene weg angesprochen
haben mein stand ist das zum beispiel
mit einem leckerli präsidenten wieder
seit monaten nicht mehr sprechen ist das
falsch
das ist nicht richtig also
wähler also im hat urlaubsbedingt also
an den letzten allerletzten also
bundespressekonferenz
nicht teilnehmen können und ist aber
also in diesen wichtigen fragen auf
leitungsebene
kompetent und äquivalent vertreten das
hätte war mir dann die kollegin rechts
wie auch immer es beantworten will
bleibt es bei der regelung wonach von
tess pflichten menschen ausgenommen sind
die frisch geimpft oder genesen sind
also eine ähnliche dreimonats regelung
bei der frage krankenhäuser und
pflegeheime danke nein dabei ist es
nicht geblieben also diese
ausnahmeregelung gilt und krankenhäuser
und pflegeeinrichtungen nicht wir haben
dort das also schutzniveau dort nicht
erhöht dahingehend dass dort sowohl die
maske getragen werden muss die zwei
maske getragen werden muss und getestet
werden muss aber eine ausnahmeregelung
also für geimpfte frisch kämpfte oder
frisch genesene besteht nicht mehr wir
haben auch also wir haben uns also in
diesem bereich dafür entschieden mehr
schutz anzubieten das gleiche gilt auch
für den also fernverkehr das ja jetzt
zweimal vorgesehen situation ist einfach
die dass die omikron b a 5 variante so
hoch ansteckend ist das tatsächlich hier
ein gutes schutzniveau nur durch also
qualitativ hochwertige masken erreichbar
ist und dass wir also die testung
zusätzlich in den medizinischen
einrichtungen vorsehen ja ich da
vielleicht eine anmerken dazu machen
hier zeigt sich die verbraucher
transparent wir haben vor drei wochen
unser entwurf vorgestellt und dann war
ja diese ausnahme sicherlich das am
meisten diskutierte auch kritisch
diskutierte element und da ist auch
vieles missverstanden worden als wie ich
dazu sagen also vieles was über diese
regelung behauptet worden ist vom info
oder was es sonst noch alles gibt gab
der entwurf er überhaupt nicht her
trotzdem haben wir natürlich auf diese
debatte reagiert und zwar an zwei
stellen das eine ist eben dass wir diese
ausnahme bei den krankenhäusern
gestrichen haben und das hatte kollege
lauterbach ja schon geschildert dass wir
aus dieser pflicht ausnahme wenn länder
denn zum instrument der masken in rom
greifen wollen das wird daraus eine
ermessensentscheidung der länder gemacht
haben und das zeigt auch die transparent
das verfahren ist und dass wir auch auf
kritik hier natürlich reagieren
dann gehen wir nach rechts hätten sie
glaube ich beide gemeldet und so konnten
spiekermann zdf hauptstadtstudio danke
hält liedchen ich habe die frage zu es
nicht überraschen zur twitter und erst
dann die bilder von dem kanzler und
harbeck ohne maske gereist sind
gleichzeitig seien sie heute
dass sie die regelungen an bord
verschärfen also keine op masken mehr
sondern fc2 wie passt das zusammen
er hat zunächst einmal also die regeln
der flugbereitschaft sind eingehalten
worden und darüber hinaus ist sogar so
ein test
gemacht worden für alle mitgeflogen sind
die regeln die wir jetzt hier
verschärfen dass es eine antwort quasi
auf die epidemiologischen gegebenheiten
also die grundüberlegung ist die wenn
man schon aus so eine maske trägt im
fernverkehr wo das risiko der ansteckung
hoch ist bei der omicron b a 5 variante
dann soll die maske auch wirken und da
hat man einfach einen deutlich besseren
schutz wenn man an effect 2 maske trägt
ja ich kann zu den abläufen vielleicht
etwas sagen wenn ein solcher umstand am
tage vor einer kabinettsentscheidung
bekannt wird dann lasst uns die abläufe
gar nicht zu selbst wenn man wollte ja
jetzt änderung vorzunehmen
mein gefühl ist dass sich das parlament
noch einmal damit beschäftigen wird und
meine persönliche meinung ist das ist
jetzt keine rechtliche einschätzung denn
es ist in der tat exakt so wie kollege
lauterbach gesagt hat dass die internen
regelungen der flugbereitschaft
eingehalten worden sind politisch würde
ich uns empfehlen als bundesregierung
dass wir überall die gleichen regeln
anwenden die auch sonst gelten denn
sonst entsteht natürlich das gefühl dass
man den bürgerinnen und bürgern bereit
ist etwas zuzumuten was man sich selber
nicht zumuten möchte und deshalb kann
ich auch ein stück weit verstehen dass
er soviel darüber gesprochen haben sie
noch eine zusatzfrage schauspieler man
steht nicht nur das gefühl dass ja fakt
also nur um sie zu ergänzen und wie sie
sagen auch herr minister es gibt eigene
regeln für die luftwaffe also
wie kann denn das sein also das ist das
sozusagen das rechtfertige sein
ja es ist ebenso es gibt eigene regeln
für die luftwaffe und für die
flugbereitschaft und die sind hier zum
einsatz gekommen und über diese regeln
hinaus sind dann diejenigen die
mitgereisten noch getestet worden mehr
kann ich dazu nicht sagen somit die
regeln gehalten sind eingehalten worden
und darüber hinaus fand der test statt
der verbleibenden gerechnet
christiane hübscher ebenfalls vom zdf
dann vielleicht noch mal an wie herr
muss man die frage es gilt ja trotzdem
die regel dass auf allen flügen von und
nach deutschland wie masken pflicht gilt
das ist ein flug gewesen von deutschland
egal ob auch in der luftwaffe oder von
der lufthansa ausgeführt wurde auf
welcher gesetzlichen grundlage ist es
dann hier anders entschieden wurde also
mehr reicht eigentlich begründung nicht
zu sagen die luftwaffe hat da ihre
eigene regeln
also ich führe ja nicht die aufsicht
weder über den luftverkehr noch über die
luftwaffe deshalb haben wir keine
eigenen also prüfungs kompetenzen im
haus es gibt das
luftverkehrsgesetz da gibt es gewisse
hinweise dass dort an das geld es gibt
gedanken die es plausibel machen lassen
das für flugzeuge der luftwaffe
natürlich auch etwas anderes gelten kann
wenn sie in so einen kampf schickt
sitzen und ohnehin eine maske auf haben
aber das sind alles fachfragen die keine
das bundesverteidigungsministerium
erläutern auf welcher grundlage diese
regeln ausgegeben worden sind das ist
nicht die zuständigkeit des bmj und was
ich politisch für klug fehlte das habe
ich ja vorhin gesagt dass es politisch
klug wäre jedenfalls in vergleichbaren
situationen wo eine maschine genutzt
wird wie eine andere linienmaschine auch
dann dort am besten die gleichen regeln
anzuwenden auf welcher grundlage auch
immer im zweifelsfall sogar freiwillig
weil das dann führen durch vorbildlich
zu samstag folgt danach setzt rechnen
sie damit dass das im parlamentarischen
verfahren wird vom bundestag
noch mal geändert wird dass diese regel
fällt also zunächst möchte ich sagen wir
haben ja jetzt hier eine
formulierungshilfe erstellt wo wir beide
sagen damit kann man arbeiten und ich
will mich davon auch in keiner weise
distanzieren oder so was aber natürlich
klar ist und das war immer mein anliegen
dass das letzte wort in der korona
politik das parlament wählt also die
sogenannte re parlamentarisierung das
werden sie wissen dass kennen sie seit
über zwei jahren war immer mein anliegen
weil und rechts relevante dinge
abschließend im parlament entschieden
werden müssen dass der vorgang jetzt
eine debatte ausgelöst hat ist ja klar
und das ich kannte das ich mir
vorstellen kann dass das im parlament
einmal diskutiert wird das liegt ja auch
im bereich der der lebens
wahrscheinlichkeit und deshalb kann das
natürlich niemand ausschließen wir haben
ja auch schon viele abgeordnete sich
dazu äussern hören deshalb gehe ich
davon aus dass da sicherlich nochmal
drüber gesprochen wird und was dann
entschieden wird das entscheidet der
gesetzgeber das parlament und das ist
auch richtig so dann hatte ich glaube
sie sind verdeckt die kolleginnen 1
hinter gemeldet bitte und die braut dann
gleich nochmal anzeichen wer noch fragen
hat christin beck ard hauptstadtstudio
frage nochmal zu den masken
was ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden
habe
lauterbach vor allen dingen warum ist
denn ein test der doch deutlich
sichereren maske gleichgestellt also vor
allen dingen als muss regelt das
verwirrt mich ein bisschen weil das sind
ja dann wahrscheinlich trotzdem wieder
schnelltest wir wissen die funktionieren
gut wenn man hohe währungs last hat und
schon richtig krank ist aber auch
manchmal beiwohnen virus lasten nicht so
gut also ich verstehe nicht ganz warum
das ein mus regel ist das der test
sozusagen auf jeden fall die maske
ersetzen kann und quasi ohne
zwangsmaßnahmen sogar bildet und es
würde ja dann im alltag auch dazu führen
dass man eine veranstaltung hat wo die
hälfte mit maske und die andere hälfte
ohne ist aber wenn die dann länger geht
wird der keiner mehr irgendwie ein
überblick haben ob der ohne maske
wirklich den test hatte wenn eine
veranstaltung mit 100 leuten das wie
soll das kontrolliert werden also ich
finde dass verwalter
vielen dank zunächst einmal also wir
haben die regeln dahingehend verschärft
dass also die ausnahme die die länder
anbieten müssen zur masken pflicht wenn
sie die masken pflicht einführen nur
noch der test ist das also vereinfacht
die gegner etwas
und das macht epidemiologisch schon in
den einrichtungen wo das dann passieren
wird nach das sinn wenn beispielsweise
in einem restaurant also die masken
pflicht gilt und die menschen gehen mit
der maske rein also was ein schutzniveau
ist aber nehmen dann platzt und sitzen
dann da eine stunde ohne maske dann ist
natürlich also der schutz nicht perfekt
ein guter schutz abakan perfekter schutz
da ist der test dann schon besser denn
wenn man dann sozusagen getestet in das
restaurant reingeht ist nicht infiziert
dann
[Musik]
sitzt man dort als also getestet und ist
wahrscheinlich weniger ein risiko für
andere als wenn man nur rein gegangen
ist mit der maske dann ausgezogen das
kann daher schon sinn machen kann aber
auch so sein dass also der veranstalter
hingeht und sagt ich lasse jetzt nur
getestete rein oder ich lasse nur
menschen mit masken keiner sagen wir
über das hausrecht ausdrücklich also
haben wir es zugelassen ich kann nur
soviel sagen ich höre immer dass die
tests also nicht so zuverlässig sind und
so weiter und so fort bei der bh 5
variante bei der foren viruslast die
typischerweise auch zu erwarten ist also
bei denjenigen die es infiziert sind
sprechen die test in der regel an dem
punkt wo man ansteckend ist sehr gut an
das ist ja insbesondere bei geimpften so
also bei geimpften ist es so dass man
oft schon symptome hat bevor man
überhaupt ansteckend ist war die impfung
führt dazu dass sozusagen der körper
sehr schnell reagiert noch wenig virus
last und dann erst kommen die wehren und
ein stark wie wir uns lassen wir uns
auch einer der gründe weshalb quasi die
impfungen die panne begrenzen weil sehr
häufig sind die leute schon mit
symptomen unterwegs und bleiben dann
auch zu hause noch bevor sie wirklich
ansteckend sind weil bei demjenigen der
geimpft ist die symptome oft beginnen
bevor die viruslast sehr hoch ist das
ist bei ungenutzten ganz anders bei
ungeimpften ist zuerst die views as sehr
hoch und dann kommt die symptome aber in
der kombination also viele geimpfte die
reinkommen
und also dann also quasi test also beim
einlass kann man die gastronomie glaube
ich schon ganz gut in den griff bekommen
und daher ist diese idee dass wir das
verpflichtend vorgeben glaube ich
epidemiologisch sinnvoll also wenn man
sich überlegt wo wir das sinn machen
gastronomie cafés und so weiter und so
fort wenn das jetzt veranstaltungen sind
wo die leute herum stehen und man wegen
da sind jetzt da sind also mit wir sind
100 leute das sind 70 mit der maske
reingegangen und nachher und 30 mit den
test und nachher sich dann nur noch
leute ohne maske dann wird es
tatsächlich so sein dass man nach
kontrollieren muss aber das ist dann ja
durch die wahren app die ich jetzt
wieder nicht zeige also ist dass der
einfach weil man die grüne waren
abzusehen ist ich glaube aber auch dass
die veranstaltung sehr schnell begreifen
werden wenn die lage unübersichtlich ist
lässt sich schwer kontrollieren man sehe
ich das genauso wie kollege buschmann
das eben vollkommen zutreffend also
vorgetragen hat dann wird man das
hausrecht so ausgestalten dass der
kontrollaufwand möglichst niedrig ist
und ich darf einmal kurz erklären warum
man die frage stellt warum haben wir das
gemacht so und nicht anders weil das ein
stück
verantwortbare normalität ermöglicht
selbst wenn eine maßgeblich verhängt
wird und weil es bestimmte
veranstaltungen gibt die machen mit
maske einfach keinen sinn sie werden
jede menge public viewings haben zur wm
wo die leute singen und sich freuen
wollen und ihre mannschaft anfeuern
wollen sich aufregen sie wir haben hier
in berlin in der stadt der singles jede
menge single gratis mit der maske macht
das irgendwie wenig sinn sie haben hier
clubs überall in der republik wo die
leute die jungen leute bei 130 140 bpm
tanzmann auf der tanzfläche wenn die dem
wasser auf der nase dann macht das
keinen spaß die alternative wäre dass
das alles nicht mehr möglich wäre aber
und deshalb haben wir darüber
nachgedacht dass wir sagen wollen selbst
wenn eine landesregierung von der masken
pflicht gebrauch macht muss es eben für
solche veranstaltungen eine möglichkeit
geben verantwortbar auch eine
veranstaltung ohne maske durchzuführen
weil sie sonst gar nicht durchgeführt
wurde und das ist genau die idee
dahinter
dass es auch weiterhin möglichkeiten
gibt im verwaltungsdeutsch heißt das
tanz lustbarkeiten und solche dinge
durchzuführen verantwortbar und warum
das epidemiologische verantwortbar ist
hat herr kollege lauterbach erneut ich
habe drei ukrainer und jetzt noch die
versuche ich noch dran zu nehmen zwei
spiegel -mann ich habe ja auch gesehen
und frau beck hat noch eine zusatzfrage
bitte anfrage dazu aber wenn sie das so
erklären schön und gut aber dann wäre ja
von der logik her zumindest was die
gastro angeht weil also mache ich denn
der ganz los ja ihnen wird man gehe dann
seinen platz und hat kanada die maske
auf das ist ja so dann wäre es doch
sinnvoller gleich zu sagen es gibt die
allgemeine testpflicht dann in dieser
ersten stufe und nicht die massen
pflicht
also erstmal muss man ja sagen sie sind
so ein bisschen glaube ich herauszuhören
in der logik drin es ginge noch darum
jede einzelne infektion in jedem fall
möglichst zu verhindern aus dieser phase
der pandemie bekämpfung sind wir raus
sondern wir arbeiten mit maßnahmen die
den die sinn und zweck verfolgen
insgesamt das infektionsgeschehen nicht
so außer kontrolle
geraten zu lassen dass wir eben diese
schweren probleme bekommen und deshalb
ist natürlich die dämpfung der pandemie
also ein bisschen flirten sie curve nur
auf etwas höherem niveau sind uns werk
und deshalb geht es gar nicht darum jede
einzelne ansteckung zu finden
insbesondere weil die menschen ja sich
selber entscheiden ein café aufzusuchen
sondern es geht darum insgesamt das
infektionsgeschehen in einem maß zu
halten dass es uns als gesellschaft
keine unerträglichen probleme macht und
gleichzeitig eben auch mal
verhältnismäßig ist die leute nicht
überfordert und den menschen in einer
schwierigen lage die er nicht nur wegen
krone angespannt ist auch noch ein
bisschen normalität ermöglicht und
deshalb ist das glaube ich ein guter
auch gesellschaftspolitisch guter
kompromiss
im einsatz dazu die regeln müssen hat
einfach sein und eine einfache regel ist
jetzt hier also es kommt dann die masken
pflicht und der test kann die ausnahme
sein somit also ist das tatsächlich um
die regeln einfach 2 ich gehe sowieso
davon aus wären wir sehr hohe fallzahlen
haben wir werden auch noch mal eine
kampagne machen wo die risiken von longo
wird klar also erläutert werden für
junge leute aber auch für ältere leute
das ist bisher zu wenig gemacht worden
aber wir haben sehr präzise dass ruhe
also besonders risiko was von longbow
wird ausgeht noch einmal erklären werden
auch erklären dass diejenigen die jetzt
also wiederholt sich infizieren und
wegen im sommer infiziert waren im märz
schon wieder und erwartungsvoll tasten
longo witt risiko steigt und zwar
wahrscheinlich sogar überproportional
wenn die menschen das verstehen dann
glaube ich schon dass es auch viele
restaurants geben wird die einfach so
schlicht und ergreifend nur getestete zu
lassen weil die restaurants die das
nicht machen die werden wir schauen dass
ich auch nicht so fühlen denn wer will
denn dann das risiko eingehen wer wie
das risiko eingehen
und dann gehen damit ja fabian busch von
web.de und gmx wenn ich es richtig
verstanden habe werden ja test jetzt
wieder eine größere rolle spielen ist es
aus ihrer sicht denkbar dass dann etwas
gemacht wird dass die bürger test nicht
mehr für alle kostenlos sind wäre ja
auch ein möglicher kostenfaktor im
alltag wenn man dann in den im herbst
winter rega weist mich zwei drei tage
pro woche bezahlt
also wir haben bisher
die also 3 euro regelungen ganz gut
umgesetzt das heißt die tests werden
weiter in anspruch genommen und es gibt
auch über uns viele testzentren die auf
die also im eigenen antrags verzichten
nichtsdestotrotz also ist es richtig
dass das also eine belastung sein kann
ich denke mir auch dass die länder also
bei der einführung der massen pflicht
sich überlegen werden ob sie nicht die
also zusätzlich
also kann regelungen für die geimpften
und für die genesenen nutzen werden denn
der ein oder andere der wird also dann
sicherlich auch also durch also die die
impfung wir genossen hat also wird also
dann an der test weg vorbei kommen
sicherlich ist das etwas was wir weiter
diskutieren werden aber zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt ist sie ist das regelwerk
insgesamt rund und abgeschlossen
und wird von der rheinischen post
herr buschmann sie hatten jetzt viel von
eigenverantwortung auf freiheiten
gesprochen im vergangenen juli gab es
laut lka
2839 sowie todesfälle im juli davor 20
21 waren es 274 nur im jahr davor im
juli 136 was aus ihrer sicht und auch
aus ihrer sicht herr lauterbach trotzdem
verantwortungsvoll und maßvoll die
korona schutzbestimmungen oder maßnahmen
so weit zurück zu fahren
also
wir haben ja im früher uns dafür
entschieden einen großen teil der
maßnahmen zurückzunehmen ich glaube dass
wir insgesamt natürlich vor dem
hintergrund dass menschen sterben ist
jeder einer zu viel also das ist im
moment so rabl man kann jetzt nicht
sagen es gibt einen punkt der ist
erträglich oder nicht aber wir müssen
auf der anderen seite auch sehen dass
wir den menschen auch ein stück weit
normalität so stark wie möglich auch
ermöglichen wir sind eine freie
gesellschaft und ich glaube dass im
nachhinein viele von denen die sich
gewünscht hätten dass wir maßnahmen über
den sommer fortsetzen auf die wir jetzt
verzichtet haben am ende der meinung
sind dass die lage sich viel besser
entwickelt hat als sie befürchtet haben
insbesondere mit blick auf die kritische
infrastruktur insbesondere mit blick auf
die stabilität des gesundheitssystems
und viele viele leute die am anfang
früher skeptisch waren ob das richtig
ist diese maßnahmen zurückzunehmen geben
mir mittlerweile recht und das hat
glaube ich auch dazu beigetragen die
akzeptanz für die maßnahmen noch übrig
bleiben zu erhöhen und deshalb glaube
ich können wir im nachhinein nachdem wir
mit dem wissen von heute sagen dass wir
im frühjahr richtig gehandelt haben
vielleicht nur so viel das ganze zeit
natürlich also wie kann natürlich nicht
mit der zahl der toten die wir jetzt
jeden tag hier beklagen zufrieden sein
damit kann niemand zufrieden sein ich
finde es auch schade dass darüber so
wenig gesprochen ich mir fast dankbar
für ihre frage ist ja keine unkritische
frage aber trotzdem so wichtige frage
und das zeigt nur dass wir diese regeln
im herbst wirklich sehr ernst nehmen
müssen also die verschärfung die wir
jetzt vorsehen sind aus meiner sicht
unbedingt notwendig und ich hoffe dass
die länder tatsächlich den rahmen auch
nutzen weil wir fangen an uns an die
hohe zahl von todesopfern und auch die
sehr hohe zahl von longo witwen zu
gewöhnen und das dürfen wir nicht das
ist aus meiner sicht sehr wichtig dass
wir das was wir das begreifen sind nicht
in der ende mai angekommen keineswegs
der absolut schwierig werden ich weiß
das niemand gerne hört also viele also
können es nicht mehr hören die finden
das nervig und denken das ist jetzt
nicht der richtige zeitpunkt während das
problem jetzt auch schon wieder aber was
man sich das ganz wichtig dass wir ernst
nehmen nach wie vor sterben so viele
menschen nach wie vor werden so viele
junge leute auch schwer krank chronisch
krank daher müssen wir dieses
instrumentarium anwendern und ich hoffe
dass das parlamentarische verfahren
daher auch nicht zu einer entschärfung
führt war diese regeln sind wirklich das
was wir benötigen so jede frage bitte
und dann hat ein super spiel kann man
glaube ich in die frage angemeldet dann
kommen sie noch dran und dann hauen wir
um zur regierungspressekonferenz bittet
er hat der kollege hat einer und dann
haben sie die letzte ja danke andreas
goldschmidt deutsche welle in bezug auf
die evaluierung der gefahrenlage
insbesondere für diese zweite stufe wird
vorgegeben
welche werte maßgeblich seien würden sie
denn oder
intensivstationen belegen oder das kann
ich recht einfach erklären das ist ja
eine regelungstechnik die wir schon
kennen aus der sogenannten hotspot
regelung also die zweite stufe gezündet
werden auf formaler ebene wenn der
landtag fest stellt also wir brauchen
einen mehrheitsbeschluss im landtag
transparent parlamentarisch demokratisch
legitimiert der feststellt dass eine so
genannte konkrete gefahr für kritische
infrastruktur insbesondere die
stabilität des gesundheitswesens besteht
ich weiß für journalisten kling konkrete
gefahr sehr offen aber für
verwaltungsjuristen ist es ein klassisch
definierter begriff ich konnte zu einem
lehrbuch definition sagen also wenn bei
ungehindert und ohne konkrete tatsachen
vorliegen die bei ungehindertem fortgang
auf der basis erfahrungs
wissenschaftlicher zusammenhänge zum
verlust des rechts gut führen und das
rechtsgut um das es geht er ist eben die
funktionstüchtigkeit der kritischen
infrastruktur und des gesundheitswesens
und dafür haben wir den ländern auch
noch zusätzliche parameter an die hand
gegeben die wir also im gesetz finden
nämlich in einer zusammenschau aus
beispielsweise bettenbelegung inzidenz
abwasser screenings und so weiter und so
fort also das finden sie alle im gesetz
muss sich ergeben dass diese tatsachen
wenn sie sich so weiter fortsetzen dann
wirklich zu einer beeinträchtigung der
funktionsfähigkeit führen also sprich
dass die feuerwehr nicht mehr regelmäßig
ausdrucken konnte oder dass die polizei
den streifendienst nicht mehr ordentlich
gewährleisten könnte oder dass die
krankenhäuser nicht mal ordentlich
arbeiten konnten und das ist eigentlich
relativ präzise umschrieben und dass
deutsche gerichte und deutsche
verwaltung auch damit umgehen können
haben wir ja im sommer gesehen denn ein
bundesland hat damit gearbeitet haben
die gerichte die grenzen aufgezeigt dass
die die überschritten haben und ein
anderes bundesland hat davon gebrauch
gemacht haben die verwaltungsgerichte
die regeln gehalten also wir haben
eigentlich erfahrungen damit und deshalb
werden die landesverwaltung damit auch
vernünftig umgehen können ja nur ganz
kurz also wir haben die regeln hier so
gemacht hat sie tatsächlich auch
angewendet werden können hier ist von
einer gesamtschau die rede das heißt sie
können alle elemente die in diesem band
emirat in welches einführung der
erstmalig ist also im herbst kommt
genutzt werden wieviel intensivbetten
sind noch frei wie viel gemacht werden
sind noch frei wie viele leute liegen
ankommt wie schwer sind die erkannt wie
viele menschen sterben pro tag also wie
ist die kritische infrastruktur bedroht
somit ein gesamtbild kann da also
herangezogen werden und mit damit kann
argumentiert werden dass also jetzt
diese also sagen verschärften maßnahmen
herangezogen werden müssen die
ich bin selbst kein jurist aber ich habe
sehr präzise auswerten lassen auch durch
meine juristischen fachleute waren
regeln gut funktionieren und vor gericht
bestand haben die haben dann bestand
wenn ein gesamtbild gemalt werden kann
und dieses gesamtbild kann gut begründet
werden so dass sich quasi einen eindruck
so ableiten lässt was würde passieren
wenn wir jetzt nichts unternehmen und
diese regelung also daher auf habe ich
auch großen wert gelegt zusammen mit
herrn buschmann so gemacht dass sie in
der praxis auch eingesetzt werden können
werden die fallzahlen steigen letzte
bitte kurze frage von frau spiel kann
man dann müssen wir zum ende kommen sie
sagen beide als minister das ist jetzt
viel klarheit gibt dass die klare
regelung gefunden haben es gibt aber
viele verwirrungen auch in der
bevölkerung also was gilt jetzt was gilt
nicht fühlen sich eigentlich manchmal
selbst befangen diesen regelungen die
sie jetzt mühsam in kompromissen
gefunden haben zwischen spd und fdp nein
also zunächst einmal dass die leute sich
fragen was jetzt kommt und dass viele
natürlich noch erinnerungen an die
letzten zwei corona winter haben die
objektiv ja sehr viel schwerere
maßnahmen gezeigt haben als es jetzt vor
sind dass die leute sich sorgen machen
das doch klar also insbesondere wenn es
um gastronomen geht um veranstaltungen
sagen was kommt da jetzt wie geht es
hier mit meinem geschäft weiter und weil
es doch völlig klar
und dann gibt es natürlich auch viel
desinformation also täglich lese ich in
den sozialen medien es kommt doch
irgendwie der lockdown durch die
hintertür als es wird auch wirklich viel
propaganda viel fake news verbreitet und
solche veranstaltungen wie hier dienen
ja dazu dass wir den menschen
transparent aufzeigen was wirklich in
dieser formulierungshilfe steht und ich
glaube auch das parlamentarische
verfahren wird dazu beitragen dass die
menschen erkennen was wirklich die
regelungen sind dann wird man erkennen
dass das ein
vernünftiges instrumentarium ist das maß
voll ist und mit dem man dann auch in
der praxis gut wird arbeiten ja
also ich würds simple weise wie folgt
ausdrücken was wir gemacht haben ist wir
haben die regeln genutzt werden können
sehr stark vereinfacht und also
reduziert ist es noch massen pflicht
ahnt es im fond genießen status und wenn
also wenn es mehr wird dann obergrenzen
aber mehr ist es ja nicht wir haben aber
gleichzeitig dafür gesorgt dass diese
regeln sehr viel früher eingesetzt
werden können und dass es besser
erkennbare und leichtere also regeln
gibt zu verschärfen somit weniger regeln
aber leichter und schneller einsetzbar
so würde ich es also zusammenfassen
vielen dank wir sind am ende dieser
pressekonferenz hier geht es gleich
weiter mit der regierungs pässe von
verlangen danke für ihren besuch